We've solved the equations with fractions, now let's see how we can use a
similar approach to work with decimals. Here I have 2 and 3 10th times n plus 4
98 100th equals 3 times n plus 2 and 6 10th. Notice how I read these place
values as 10th and this as 100th. If I want to remove the decimals from my
equation I would multiply by a number that moves the decimal point to the right.
We can multiply both the left by a 100 and the right by a 100. If we remember
back from scientific notation multiplying by 100 moves the decimal 2 places to
the right. Now I have an equation just made up of integers. See if you can solve
the rest of this problem. And, notice too about the last step that you'll do.
Think about why that happens.